Hi. I’m Kevin. Let’s talk about Vsauce2.
When I first started making Vsauce videos,
Michael and I were each making different
shows for both Vsauce and Vsauce2. Vsauce!
Kevin here. In the 11 years since I started
doing Vsauce2 full-time, I’ve developed a
dozen formats across hundreds of videos that
have been viewed 3 quarters of a billion times.
The truth is that the old YouTube is gone
-- everything is different now. I just feel
like... making my style of educational
content sustainably is impossible.
So…this channel as you know is just done.
It’s just time that I do...
I don’t know… something else.
Please bring back Mind Blow. Why did you
quit Mind Blow? Will there ever be another
Mind Blow? Can we get more MindBlow?
Mind used to inspire and motive me...
Bring back Mind Blow.
Hey, Kevin. Bring back Mind Blow. You coward.
Hey, Kevin! Bring back Mind Blow!
Do it!
Bring back Mind Blow! Mind Blow, please!
Listen. Everyone. For the last time. I
am NOT bringing back Mind Blow. YOU ARE.
Vsauce2 was built on the backbone of a show
highlighting the latest in science news,
robotics, experimental technology, and
amazing inventions. Some things that
seemed futuristic at the time like wireless
charging or digital face filters are now
completely commonplace. Other things like
“invisibility skin” we’re still waiting on.
It was called Mind Blow. I LOVED that show -- and
it’s been 5 years since the last episode.
I even did a podcast about why I stopped,
but everyday I receive comments from
you asking to bring back Mind Blow.
So here it is. The Bring Back Mind Blow Project.
YOU will produce brand new episodes of Mind
Blow starting right now. Your involvement in
the Bring Back Mind Blow Project will directly
support hiring Emmy award-winning science writer
Scott Frank. Say hi, Scott. “Hi Scott.” As well
hiring a dedicated researcher, video editor,
thumbnail artist, fact-checker, media manager, and
all the aspects of properly returning Mind Blow to
Vsauce2. I’m even gonna end every episode with
the original NES cartridge squeeze Vsauce2 logo.
YOUR role as Producer will
include submitting story ideas,
voting on thumbnails, engaging in
great discussions about science news,
and seeing your name credited for bringing
back Mind Blow. Because Mind Blow is your show.
The number of episodes every month is
up to you. We’ll start with one -- with
your support we can make two, and if things
get really crazy I've got ideas for that.
Not only will patrons receive exclusive bonus Mind
Blow content but I have a way bigger announcement
than that. The first Mind Blow episode in five
years is ALREADY DONE and it’s available to watch
right now exclusively to patrons – this episode
will never be uploaded publicly to YouTube.
It’s just for you. So if you want to
watch it you have to become part of
The Bring Back Mind Blow Project. After
that every new episode will be uploaded
for free to YouTube thanks entirely
to those of you who join the project.
So now’s the time for you to become part of
Bringing Back Mind Blow. Go to Patreon.com/Vsauce2
or click the link in the description. I will still
be doing long-form, deep-dive videos -- there are
a LOT of topics I want to investigate -- but you
are returning Mind Blow to this channel, too.
Some of you grew up with Mind Blow. Some of
you now have kids old enough to watch Mind
Blow with you. And yeah, YouTube has changed --
but with your help, we can do science news right
again. Forget the content farms and every
other problem with YouTube. We’re going
back to our roots. Reject modernity, return to
tradition -- and become a producer for Mind Blow.
Patreon.com/Vsauce2. This is Mind Blow. YOU are
Mind Blow. Join the Bring Back Mind Blow Project.
Now.